how to grow in YouTube the other video I
did on how to get started on YouTube I
was fairly well received and a lot of
people seem to appreciate it and yeah
you know that Buddhist quote about
passing on knowledge that you have I
don't know what but I think there was
something about just you should do it
so is kind of ironic for me to say how
to grow your channel especially since my
neck completely flatlined and it's not
growing at all anymore
but I get the question all the time from
young youtubers people starting off and
and they want to come to me for advice
on these things first of all don't look
at anything that I'm doing right now as
a okay he's doing this he's the biggest
channel so I should do this I couldn't
be further from from wrong way of doing
things
I clearly stopped trying I'm not trying
to grow my channel anymore I'm just
thankful with the audience that I have
I'm not trying to push [ __ ] to see oh
can we hit a hundred million can we do
it there's no right and wrong in these
things I think then how to grow on
YouTube then you're gonna get a
different answer from any different
youtuber that answers the question and I
hate to make it seem like I am the only
one who knows this thing and I'm the
only one who has the right answer cuz
that's not true at all I can only speak
from my experience pretty much and
that's what I'm gonna do going back
seven years ago when I started making
videos like I said before I was making
Call of Duty videos I felt frustrated as
hell and I and I that's why I sympathize
with youtubers that come to me for
advice on how to grow their channel
because I've been there I know how it
feels like to to make videos and your
channel is not growing at all and you're
just wondering like why I'm making good
content why is no one watching it and
just that feeling that you have more to
give but it's not going anywhere it's
extremely frustrating but the first
thing I noticed was - I know it's
obvious this this is obvious but just
mentioning the people to subscribe at
the end of the video I think I mentioned
this before but I know it was the first
thing that I noticed that really helped
bring in a lot more subscribers if
what you care about some people would
say no I'm not gonna do that I think my
audience is intelligent enough to figure
it out themselves if they enjoyed my
video they will subscribe they will just
do it and I have a lot of respect for
that approach but I see it more as a
reminder you know hey you you enjoyed
the video and maybe you should subscribe
it's a button right here I don't think
that hurts but uh there's also the other
end of the spectrum where people
literally before the video even begins
go like subscribe to this video and that
probably will get you more subscribers
I'm not gonna lie but probably no one
will like you they should respect you at
least that's how I see it
it's all about finding that balance of
what you feel comfortable with I mean
there's even people who do YouTube in a
completely different perspective than
mine instead of growing an audience they
just focus on viral videos and they get
shit-ton abuse from doing that they they
wouldn't benefit from having a
subscriber base at all even telling
people reminding people to subscribe
it's only gonna get you as far with the
video that you're making like I was
making call of duty videos because
everyone else was making call of duty
videos and I didn't know what else to
make I had no idea I just enjoyed making
videos the thing is people are already
subscribed to the big guys you know
they're not gonna care about some new
little [ __ ] it's not how it is
I think I see this in a lot of people
that follow sort of my style and maybe
jack and mark style cos is sort of
similar you know I I feel for them
because I understand their perspective
but it's also like well you're not
filling a need does that make sense if
you look at yourself as a product if you
come in as a sort of a clone as another
youtuber you're not filling a need
that's not there you know you're not
offering a product I'm sorry for
speaking at such a business perspective
but you're not you're not meeting a
demand that is doesn't exist that
doesn't already exist so I would say
there's no shame at all in doing what
everyone else is doing but I think if
you care about growing an audience and
and
making it bigger on YouTube you're gonna
have to eventually carve out your own
style your own thing what makes you
different what makes you unique and
that's what I personally find
interesting in and other youtubers is
somewhat something different you know
something you haven't seen before and if
you find that it's hard you know finding
that is it's it's almost impossible and
you're lucky if you do I'm not gonna lie
it's not that easy I think if you really
really really you know want to grow your
channel you need something to set you
apart
I switched up my content because of a
random thing I was like well I'm too
scared to play this game so I might as
well film it but I could tell you know
immediately people responded well to it
so I would just say test out different
things you know don't always do the same
thing and eventually just go with the
flow you know if people respond well to
something go with it you know you got to
make decisions twists and turns go with
the flow but when I was making the
horror games my audience was loving it
you know then once that watched the
content they were super into it it was
easy you know but it didn't really grow
my channel that much because you know
they were what 20 minute 10 minute
videos of me playing a game not everyone
has time to watch that so I would make
these compilation videos of the funniest
bits from the horror games when I was
screaming or whatever and I noticed
right away the impact of these videos
they really brought in a whole so many
new sets of eyes to my channel because
just having the content isn't enough
you're gonna have to get it out there
for other people to see bring in new
people and so I did the montages and I
really understand how powerful they were
so I really really put a lot of time a
lot of effort into them and as soon as
they went up I made sure that they were
I made a lot of time in my life enjoy I
made sure that they were easy to consume
you know it like a trailer fast cut you
know before you even know it it's it's
it's cutting super easy to consume
anyone can just watch the whole thing
and really even realize it's you watch
the whole thing
and then by the end of it you want to
leave them with some more so you tell
okay well if you
watch more subscribe and all that [ __ ]
and I really hit hard on that and I
think the montage has really helped me
tremendously
in growing my channel I you could I
could see it in the stats like I would
get a hundred thousand a day to fifty
thousand a day and that was back when
you two wasn't even that big so to get
those numbers was pretty crazy and not
saying everyone should go out there
making montages but if you have the type
of content that isn't easily consumable
then it's a good idea to make a package
maybe this is all obvious I don't know
Photoshop has helped me out so much
growing my channel
you have no idea back in the day people
didn't even bother making thumbnails
they we had the option to do the thumb
nests but most people just didn't do
them they were like I [ __ ] it I would
put so much time into the thumbnails
because I realized the impact that they
had on your video it's sort of like I
see the I see a lot of people making
this mistake and I know it sucks you
know why the thumbnail what the [ __ ]
does that have to do with the video
you know it's stupid it is I'm not gonna
lie I sort of see it as you know
entering a store you feel a lot better
entering a store with a neat design you
know front and nice interior design
doesn't necessarily have anything to do
with the product that they sell but as a
consumer you feel better entering that
right and I think it's the same thing
with YouTube and I see so many of you
guys sending me videos saying hey hey
can you check out my channel I would
really appreciate it and I see the same
mistake all the time it looks terrible
your channel looks terrible and I know
it's I and personally I'm completely
turned off at that point you know it
just looks so bad that I don't even want
to click on it and I know that's
terrible to say I'm just trying to help
you okay and the thing is as well you
don't even have to be good at Photoshop
are you terrible and making stuff in
Photoshop just do it in paint ironically
make that your thing you know make it
into a joke turn it around but seeing
these half-assed
shitty font videos I'm just like I don't
want to watch it I'm sorry I don't
this looks terrible so make your content
presentable cuz that's what's gonna make
people click on it maybe learn Photoshop
maybe do some maybe ask a friend that
can help you out maybe commissioning a
guy to help you out I don't know but I
really think it is an important step
unfortunately it's something that you're
gonna have to take care of buddy
number two is naming your videos which
is something that really really helped
that a lot I remember when the Last of
Us series came out I wasn't the biggest
channel yet but it was really close and
I wasn't sure if I would ever become the
biggest channel on YouTube and I I
remember I was thinking well I'm only
gonna get one I never expected to be
number one but I'm only gonna get one
chance in my life you know it's gonna
happen now or it is never gonna happen
so I went for it but I was really lucky
because the Last of Us came out if you
search if you search it I'm there but it
did get me 18 million views which is a
lot it's a lot so optimizing your video
you know last of us gameplay
walkthrough' played for the let's play
full game part one it's annoying as it
is it works now it's so overly saturated
you know a new game comes out everyone
is doing that everyone is doing that so
I don't know how much that's gonna help
you but it did help me a lot when really
popular games like that come out you
know having people find your video
through research it's definitely gonna
bring in more eyes now the second advice
on naming your video I learned from my
grandma who's a gallerist Oh cuz I would
make all these Photoshop things of girls
typically you know my old art and I
would just call them like sad girl or a
happy person or some [ __ ] like that
very descriptive you know and she I
remember she told me that's a that's a
bad idea you want to name your art so
that people ask you a question about it
it doesn't answer what it is it that
makes you ask a question and I sort of
took that advice into YouTube don't
click baton but you sort of want whoever
is watching the video to to ask a
question right okay what is this video
about and they also want them to answer
that question by clicking on the video
okay what is this title
saying I want to find out by clicking on
it and finally change up your content
hey it's something that I benefited so
much from every youtuber has a lifeline
- so over do you know is think of all
the number-one channels already that no
one watch it anymore
you're only gonna get as far doing the
same thing and I personally I switched
up my content because I got bored doing
the same [ __ ] over and over but it also
helped me out a lot because it kept my
audience entertained you might be lucky
you might strike gold on YouTube you
know minecraft might get really popular
and that might become your whole shtick
but unless people come for you and come
for your personality they're not gonna
stay that's why I really recommend
trying out different things no matter if
you're small or a big channel and I
think it's better to do this earlier
than later because it's easy to get
comfortable on YouTube it's easy to just
be like oh this is working why should I
do anything else you know I hope this
advice helped you out on your endeavors
on YouTube good luck I'm rooting for you
buddy and just remember to have fun with
it because if you have fun you can't
lose thanks for leaving it like and
subscribing to my channel I upload
videos every single day and that's it
squad fam out